deux très bien bel edward à dire
maintenant on va faire une interview qui
s'appelle lardy view on va baisser la
lumière il faut pas bouger par le jingle
vous avez pas bougé je méritais je vais
mais était imperturbable
vous pensez à quoi là en ce moment oui
bon je suis pas ou qu'est ce qu'il va me
demander est ce que je vais vous
demander c'est qu'est la dernière chose
que vous faites le soir avant de vous
coucher je ferme le livre que je lis
tous les soirs oui je lis de deux heures
tous les soirs où les échos en ce moment
en ce moment je lis un recueil de
nouvelles japonaise sous littérature que
je connais pas du tout et un livre de
l'épousé de jean pierre elkabbach nicole
avril n'est que la rude sur le visage
absolument le matin qu'on voyait dans la
glace vous dites quoi
il faut absolument
il faut absolument que soit ce patois
l'êtes vous en seriez quoi en vous si
vous aviez une baguette magique en moi
oui pain physiquement ce musée une
baguette magique vous changeriez quoi il
y aurait beaucoup de choses ont changé
mais c'est pas possible
y a pas de baguette magique pour quelle
est la phrase que vous ne supportez pas
d'entendre c'est difficile parce que
c'est l'alibi de toutes les deux tous
les renoncements
tout est difficile de dire à la limite
c'est pas trop divisés là pour vous
présentement
non ça va bien vous fait plaisir je très
inquiet quand avez vous pleuré pour la
dernière fois je pleure pas beaucoup ne
pleure pas beaucoup je le regrette
d'ailleurs partial de déshonneur à
pleurer non non non mais enfin c'est
comme ça je le regrette parce que ça
quand ça se produit ça soulage la
dernière fois c'était pour quelqu'un de
cher et que j'ai perdu voilà qui est la
dernière personne que vous ayez envie de
tuer j'ai jamais eu envie de tuer
personne
non mais je comprends pas la question
parce que la dernière s'impliquent on a
déjà tué quelques uns
donc on a eu envie envie envie la
dernière comme a eu envie
qu'est ce qui vous énerve le plus en
vous je suis impatient c'est un défaut
j'aime que les choses aillent vite et
parfois j'ai fait trop vite
et voilà comment aimeriez-vous mourir
bas comme tout le monde vite mais
toujours impatient mais toujours
impatients vous puisque ce qui est
terrible au fond c'est la dégradation
physique c'est pas la mort encore comme
je ne suis jamais mort jusqu'à presque
sept mois mais peut être réincarné
peut-être vous êtes un vieux incarner on
sait pas est ce que d'ailleurs si vous
étiez réincarner vous devez être incarné
ans qui en rejettent anna enrico macias
ou michel boujenah mais ce n'est pas ce
que j'ai expliqué à monsieur edouard
balladur que pendant la guerre je suis
un peu plus âgés que le monsieur
balladur qu'il a il a une attitude
extraordinairement courageuse en libye
en cyrénaïque en egypte et il a été
formidable
il a relevé le gant d'une armée
française qu'on pouvait un petit peu
pour garder à lui devenir eugène
schueller et michel boujenah
je n'ai pas là il sera fait bir-hakeim
le deux autres dernière question
monsieur que les milices dernière
question et si c'était à refaire votre
vie vous referiez quoi pas pareil dans
ma vie je voulais être médecin quand
j'étais jeune
et puis j'ai été malade et je ne sais
pas pu l'être
donc j'ai pris d'autres études qui était
à l'époque considéré comme plus facile
j'aurais quand même bien émettre médecin
merci beaucoup ont valu merci